and assume we have a better chance of
getting into the hollow shorts Film
Festival as an early submission or over
a late submission or does it does it not
matter no it doesn't know I really
doesn't matter I mean I was gonna maybe
say yeah you don't want to say doesn't
doesn't matter what it doesn't matter I
mean the honest truth is that you know
it's better similarly and we kind of you
know encourage that it's good for
different reasons obviously cheaper for
the filmmakers and easier honest you
know we can get through the process of
watching the films and all of that but
we're still going once the process all
the way through and if a film comes our
if we are open to submissions and we're
taking submissions then we're gonna have
to watch that film and treated equal
like any other film we're not gonna like
look at and say I love this movie but
you know they submitted on to first I
mean - mid last week you know that'd be
stupid you like you know I don't know if
he'll do that but that to me is it's
kind of ironic I mean you know we want
to like get the best feels possible
screen the best films we possibly can
screen and we feel the film comes our
way - we're open to submissions and
taking submissions that means we're
still open for competition we're
allowing you to submit and we're taking
your money we're gonna treat the film
equally with everything else and to put
them all each other and in the
competition setting and see what the
best films are and they'll be up for
competition enough to be selected and
that's really the bottom line I mean
yeah I don't want to get into like
thinking of things based on just the
deadlines and all the rules so much
because I don't know what's them again
we're trying to find the best films and
if we like a film don't want to show it
then and they submit it to us me
personally if you I feel like that's
just like silly just to say well you
know we liked a lot but you submit it
too late and we just couldn't program it
well then you know we shouldn't that
point you taking submissions if we're
taking submissions still and we're open
for call for entries now granted if said
that after the deadline that's a whole
different story it's but we don't really
generally want to take some films after
delegates so yeah I guess a long answer
for that but yeah it's uh you know I
guess where we're coming from with that
question then is an honour and our
experience on the other side as
filmmakers submitting to film festivals
there seems to be like if we get a film
in early there's more likelihood to get
that acceptance whereas there's
is where we submit late right and for
some reason is like any time we submit
our films late this means that they're
never accepted so how do you respond to
that yeah I think um I guess I guess I
could say I can't me speak to other
festivals but I would think that there
must be well I mean I calculate expect
ours and said we do know that there's a
certain period when we are slot in their
films we're selecting as we get closer
you know we have a certain mindset or we
know or we have this many films there
that are very highly graded and score
very well so I guess from that
standpoint you are up against it in the
sense of like you know you want to
program a certain amount already because
obviously over time you see films you
just the love of film you see in January
so this film is amazing this is good to
be this is up for this award that award
and it's gonna get in so you do have
sauce that refills right but we're not
gonna completely not with the film the
festival's not completely programmed by
the time we get submissions and say like
May or that's not the case and if it was
the Nazi that wouldn't be fair but also
that again back to my point like I if
something came our way that's like you
know first last year Asylum our won Best
Short Holly Schwartz it was submitting
like an you know I think for the regular
deadline but if that film was submitted
in I don't know the last agent first
well I would check what if I rejected
that film or what objective based on on
the room for this so we just can't sit
we can't accept your film or we just
rejected because we just didn't feel
like we had time to watch I don't know
whatever process might happen was on
these festivals we'd be losing out on
our the best film we've had in arguably
in years and we wouldn't put it in the
festival I mean I just tomatoes it makes
sense now the other side is again going
back to going back to the points other
festivals and even iq- are so we do have
to program as a process goes on and
again slots are being filled so there is
a benefit to summon earlier but another
part of this is what if your films got
finished and may you just finished in
less of it I mean you're finally ready
so you couldn't submit earlier anyway I
mean if you just got a film finished you
want to submit for this this year and
you finish your film on man you're done
color corrected post crush and die
everything's done you want to submit
then there's I mean that that individual
has no option but to submit in May or
late and that's merely because the film
was even done or maybe they just shot
the anyone else so there's that part of
as well I think for other festivals in
this case they are your speak
I think there probably is a certain
process in place where they are pretty
well program or they feel like they
don't need much more maybe they just
kind of looked at the way they feel like
you don't you know they don't need many
more films and just taking more
submissions to take submissions I don't
know I mean I can't obviously I don't
know I'm not gonna speak for others I'm
just assuming and it is challenging
there is again like I said slots filled
and you have a certain idea of what's
gonna be where but again the process is
you get the film's we're open to
submissions so we want to compete or
noncom we want to look at all the films
the whole and make decisions based on
that and try to that to be the singular
focus you know just that's what we're
trying to do not you know you submit
late you don't know time for you liked
it but no oh well you know now granted
again there's there is a sort of element
of I guess you're a little behind the
8-ball in the sense of there is a lot of
films are you come our way and our
certain films ready program but when by
no means done programming by the time we
get to that point we want to finish call
Frenchie's and then start really diving
the programming at that point you know
again when you have two competing so the
films have been scored and score high so
you know yeah but again back to how I
feel about it it's like even if that's
the case if your film is as good as any
other films then it belong to program we
never minced and not put it in the
program and select the film based
something we like it would be a mistake
and what is the submission for all the
shorts mm well runs basically we start
now in December of the year before so
like summer 2012 when we go through June
first so a full six month period
basically and then once you cut it off
it's that's done and then then at that
point we're really getting the
selections and really getting into the
programming and diving into that but up
until that time we're just do that time
we're watching films on the whole time
and the festival dates all our win dogs
14th August 15 to 20 second and we've
announced earlier we would pause 15 to
the 25th we may be stretched into ten
days and have some more work on that and
then out some things about that but
that's still in the work so the very
minimum August 15 to 20 seconds but
seven days we might we might take it to
the 25th and go
fifteen to twenty fifth for ten days
possibly they can go to Holly Schwartz
calm yeah
you